pourquoi
[Musique]
dans mon travail
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à partir d'aujourd'hui les universités
et la vo de recherche se mettaient en
grève on arrête tout pourquoi parce que
nous sommes inquiets pour notre avenir
tant au niveau de l'emploi puisqu'elle
plus en plus de précarité mais en amont
n'annonce pas de frais à son poste mais
encore des nouveaux contrats précaires
au niveau des crédits pour faire de la
recherche
on nous dit y aura de l'argent mais
c'est que dans cherche par contre a donc
encore plus de précaires et aussi les
conséquences de la loi retraites
nous sommes parmi comme les enseignants
les personnels qui ont le moins de
primes etc allons faire beaucoup
[Musique]
quand on est enseignant contractuel
l'enseigné cdd va chez les 80 de chances
et des nez voilà on enchaîne les cdd un
impact statut on n'a pas droit au
chômage
avec le procès on fait quelques heures
on est payé quelques heures mais en
réalité en un vendeur
au delà de nos heures payées qui est
bien trop grand
donc oui évidemment ça touche tu sais ça
touche le système social
globalement
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
on vient passer ses droits
[Musique]